hello everyone and welcome to another
spectacular game from round four of the
2021 fiji world cup it's etiemba crow vs
pavel poncratov
and it was not easy choosing a game to
show there were so many great games
um uh being played today uh there was um
well i've had a couple of uh guesses
which one would be the most interesting
and this one it
it simply wasn't even a question like uh
i thought okay the uh
vidiq had a great game against uh shiong
there was the miraculous escape
by by dubo versus jessie penko but this
one i think it's a really the best game
of uh
uh of uh today uh even better than than
um
the previous game magnus vs voitershake
that we've shown because it's simply
simply really really awesome uh that one
was super complicated but this one i i
think you're going to enjoy
more and uh sorry in the previous video
i thought it was uh reutership who
offered to draw it was in fact magnus
for the drawsaw
once again apologies for that uh now
getting to this uh game uh like i said
back over sponkaratov uh let's check it
out
really an awesome one so uh e4 and uh
poncrato replies with e6 he goes for the
french defense and it seems like this is
becoming a trend if you face a frenchman
you have to go for for the french
defense
uh we have d for d5 knight to c3 and now
bishop to be for the winner variation uh
sometimes even called
the the nimsovich uh we have knights to
e2
uh not the most popular option a5 is by
far the most popular but knight 32 also
played very much
uh we have d captures an e4 also uh
called the the alejan marozzi gambit as
now you win upon
but it's very hard to keep up they keep
the pawn because now white plays a3 and
now you have to go back with the bishop
and the white wins back the pawn you
don't have to you could also give up
your
bishop and after knight captures uh
defended but you can't really defend it
with knight f6 then bishop g5 again
you're gonna lose this pawn there's
no no uh saving this spawn and if you
try something like
f5 then you get to save the pawn and
then we have the
uh you know the alien maruti gambit in
in its full glory
but no one in their right mind would
play this with black in a classical game
in 2021
uh i could be wrong of course i am often
times but
i i don't think so so instead after a3
we have bishop back to e7 and now just
knight captures any
on e4 wins back the pawn knight f6 and
now
queen to d3 developing while defending
we have knight to c6 and now
bishop to e3 uh and here there is one
game
uh gideon barca uh played it against the
laos portish
back in 1951 and portugal was able to
win that game very nicely
it's a year that you know very well if
you've been following this channel for
quite some time now as we all know the
great uh
well you know what i'm going to say of
1959
but if not you know uh feel free to
check it out it's one of the greatest
tournaments ever so here instead we have
castles and it is now as of move eight
that we have a completely new game
so let's see how vacro uh deals with
this we have queen side castles
and now knights to g4 trying to take
advantage of the dark square bishop's
weird position but
white doesn't really care about this
white just plays h4
and now if you capture the bishop which
is usually a good idea then white gets
the strength in its center and uh
well he can just continue attacking here
on the king side which is what you want
to do when you have castles of opposite
on opposite sides of the board uh it's
usually a race on who will
get to attack first so maybe not
allowing this is the way to go
so here instead we have f5 dislodging
this knight
knight the g5 now uh and here h6
uh now how do you how do you play this
uh well your king set is already quite
open you already played f5 maybe h6
isn't the way to go but it's very
dangerous keeping this knight here the
other knight is coming to f4 then you're
gonna have a lot of problems guarding
this e6 pawn the queen can move
also join the attack so here black just
wants to get rid of the
knight right away so here knight back to
f3 and now
bishop to d6 uh we have g3
now not allowing any f4 action by black
and
rook to b8 now here black is saying all
right i'm not interested in a slow a5 b5
pushing maneuvers uh i'm gonna play uh
b5 right away so here rook to b8
prepares this
we have c4 now kind of stopping b5
and now black plays uh b5 all the same
so if you wanted you could play some
like
b pawn to b6 and try to you know play it
a bit slower but
black is not interested in that he just
attacks this c4 pawn
and now if you capture this uh and you
could you are defending the pawn but if
you capture it then knight uh for
example the a5 bishop is coming to d7
you're gonna attack the b5 pawn
and this is not something that the white
wants to do even if
this was good for white and i mean you
can't always calculate all the way
it's very unprincipled because uh
you you should always remember this in
your own games if you're attacking on
the king side which white
definitely is trying to do you want to
keep the center and the queen side close
so you don't want to open up
lines uh anywhere except where you're
attacking so here
white of course play c5 a very
principled decision we have bishop to e7
and now knight to f4 so quite slowly but
surely improving the the the
his setup and now b4 black also wastes
no time he attacks that queen side right
away
if you wanted you could try maybe bishop
to f6 that bishop will be very useful in
the future
uh so maybe something to consider but
black says nope we're gonna push b for
right away
as often that is the correct move so
here we have
a4 another principal decision even
though the engine kind of likes a
captures on b4 but it's not a human
thing to do you want to keep the queen
side close
no no questions asked so here b3 by
black
and now comes queen to c3 you get the
queen away from the d file because now
well the queen
and the rook are occupying the same file
and you always have to worry about the
d5 or the knight coming to e5 then if
captures you get captures opens up the d
file so something that might be useful
for white so here we have knight back to
f6
now the knight is more than interested
in coming to d5
and now bishop to b5 and this is a very
strong move but also
a great move for white because you never
really got a chance to develop your
light squad bishop
and now you get to develop it with tempo
to to uh well to a very nice square
and here knight to e4 attacking white's
queen and the problem here is if you try
to defend it
then the move we discuss knight to e5
just wins the game for white there's no
defending this for black problem is if
you try knight captures on e5
then we just capture back and then this
is under attack this is under attack
this is under attack twice and
there is not much you can do if 95 just
knight captures
and you're down too much material if you
try to gain back material then knight f6
check wins the queen and you are now
dead lost so after bishop to b5
we have knight the e4 attacking the
queen on c3 and now queen captures on b3
so very nicely done uh the bishop now
guards as uh you know serves as a shield
here
and also the e6 pawn is now uh
attacked twice so black would very much
enjoy playing a6 but
it it wouldn't really work yes you kind
of can't move the bishop but you don't
even need to knight captures any sixes
and the white white's position is just
much better
if you capture it then we capture with
check and then we can capture on a6
and if you don't uh well what else is
there there is a kind of a
very cool line for black which goes
knight a5 you attack
white's queen and now after queen to a2
because you kind of wan
want to keep this pin there's really
nothing better other than capturing
captures captures king h8 and then we
again pick up the a6 pawn
and it doesn't matter that black has a
rook here we have a pawn and bishop here
so
nicely nicely predicting everything so
instead after queen captures on b3 we
have knight to the a5 right away by
ponkartov and now queen to a2 still
attacking this pawn here
and now only now a6 uh the
thing is if you try something like rook
to f6 maybe to keep an eye on the pawn
then again
knights the e5 extremely unpleasant uh
you don't really
you don't really have a move here for
black if you play a6 now for example
bishop to c6 and what do you play
you can never capture here because then
knight captures attacks the queen and
the rook
and if you try to play any move so it
doesn't really matter let's say bishop
to d6 we just play f3
and trap the knight there's no saving
this knight if knight cop person g3 rook
g1
and again the knight is trapped so no
this is attacked
this is attacked there's nothing you can
do here so
after queen to a2 we have the immediate
a6 by black
and now comes knight captures on e6 as
planned
you could also improve just with bishop
to c4 but it doesn't really matter
knight captures an e6 we have bishop
captures and now queen captures an e6 we
have king the h8
and now uh white could capture on a6 but
etienne
didn't seem to like this so he just
played bishop to d7 completely
uh locking out uh all of black's pieces
but
allowing something that i think he he
was kind of trying to bait so this
uh this is definitely a bait as black
went for it
so here bishop to f6 a move you
definitely want to include
at any point in this game it would seem
but black played rook to f6
and now atn got exactly what he wanted
because now there's only one good move
for white you don't really have all that
many moves
um uh because your bishop hangs if you
move the queen even if you
put the queen here we can just play c6
and again it's a
it's a very uh well losing position for
white so here
after this rook to f6 we have knight to
e5
and this is just beautiful now uh rook
captures queen
kind of is the strongest move but it's a
move that leaves uh black in a very
difficult position knight f7 check king
j8 now we pick up the queen
knight captures attacking the rook here
with the bishop and the knight
so here the rook would move and now for
example 96 and we
continue playing this game but it's uh
it's definitely white who's better here
i know no questions um about it it's a
very very difficult position
for black so instead after knights the
e5
uh black did not like this you know even
though
you're surviving you're not really
enjoying your position he played the
rook captures on b2
and this is a great move unless white
finds a a really awesome refutation
so feel free to pause the video and this
is only the first of three positive
video moments that we're going to have
while i give you a couple of seconds and
of course try to find the the winning
idea for white
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
going for that headshot immediately and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's queen captures on f6
that's that's the winning idea it was
not played in the game but it's uh it's
such a cool move that you
you simply have to play it the problem
is uh and i think this is why it wasn't
played because if you accept the queen
then it's perfectly fine of course we
win this very easily knight f7 check
we're going to play king j89 captures on
d8
and you don't really have anything here
with black your rook here is hanging you
have to move the rook somewhere rook b4
now knight c6 attacks the knight in the
rook and after captures captures
well we have this position where white
is simply up a full rook
uh the problem why i think it wasn't
played this queen captures an f6 idea
is that uh well bishop captures isn't
forced you also have this rook to b1
trick
and now the problem is if the rook is
accepted then we get queen to b8 check
and now the queen might find all of
these
nice squares to continue checking the
white king and uh
it's just super ugly so the only way for
white to survive would be queen to b6
and then for example c captures we keep
the big file closed and we continue
playing this game so it's still better
for white but very very ugly
uh one thing you have to do after queen
captures on f6 and rook to b1 check
is ignore the rook king c2 and now of
course black will try to sacrifice the
rook again
king d3 we're going to play rook b or
rugby three check king e2 and now after
another checking f3 and the king is very
safe here uh but
um you know who who who who who who's
going to see that
and of course if the queen is accepted
again we go into this captures and again
we're
simply up too much material so uh
congratulations to everyone who found
rook captures an f6 but it was not
played in this game here white
accepted the challenge he played king
captures on b2 and now
queen to b8 check king to a3 luckily
there's no checkmate
the queen is guarding the b3 square and
now rook captures an e6 there's really
nothing better
for for um for you to do so uh
rook captures queen and now bishop
captures an e6 so now black is up a full
queen
but how do you how do you uh continue
from here the bishop still prevents
checkmate
so what can we do queen to b6 let's try
to get rid of that bishop and maybe
deliver checkmate
so bishop to f7 still keeping an eye on
that b3 square and now queen to f6
so what do you play here uh here we have
a move that's
really really incredible and even though
it seems like black stopped all of
white's attacking ideas uh black
prevails and finds another one now this
is not
maybe the best move in the position uh
but it's the best move uh considering
the position
if there's such a thing so here black
played bishop to g5 and this is just
amazing this is uh this is what rasheed
would do
this is what nish medina would do this
is what tal would do and this is what
atm bakro did what do you play here it's
uh
it's so ugly that you don't really have
a choice
your queen is trapped the queen has
nowhere to go all of these squares are
covered by
by other pawns or pieces so capturing
the bishop is the only way to go
unless it isn't uh feel free to pause
the video for a second time
and try to find the only defensive idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
and i i think meadows here i have to let
him in
sorry about that meadow is looking for
his walk even though he already
had one uh yeah but congratulations to
everyone who found this as
it's not that easy to find so capturing
the bishop right away
isn't the way to go capturing the pawn
on c5 that's the way to go so
congratulations to everyone who found
this
because now you actually survived now
after uh the captures on c5
you have to capture the bishop otherwise
there's simply too many black pieces
that will
allow you to uh check the check the
white king and also you've eliminated
this pawn so the queen now does have an
escape square
so you will have to capture it the
captures now we're going to play queen
captures on e5
and now uh white uh well there's really
nothing better than uh
going for a perpetual here king h7 check
now a bishop to g8 and now we have to
settle for a perpetual here because if
we
insist on playing then we get h5 and
then it's white who wins so king g5
and now of course f4 check uh we win
back the queen
kg4 captures here and now of course
white is up too much material
so after this bishop to g5 move black
missed bishop captures in c5 black
played knight captures and g5
and now uh this is all that white needed
h
captures and g5 now of course the h
point is pinned you cannot capture with
the pawn so queen captures on g5
and now rook to b1 now the rook is
coming into the attack we have g6 black
um
has to make some reading room for the
king here even though the g6 pawn will
fall at some point so rook to b8 check
king to h7
and then now comes rook to d1 this is a
really cool move because it completely
uh you know removes all of black's
counter plate there is not
a single square for this queen so the
pawn covers these two squares uh
the knight covers g4 discovered by the
pawn discovered by the rook now this is
covered by the rook so
there's no way for the queen to join the
attack uh if there is such a thing for
black here
so bishop to f6 was played but now uh
what do you play well bishop captures
and g6 of course we have king to g7
and now again there is only one winning
move for white
so feel free to pause the video for the
third time and finish this
incredible masterpiece while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that
something needs to be done
about this all this tension here because
if the
the defender of the bishop is removed
then we just lose the bishop
obviously not with the king but with the
queen
so you have to deal with that somehow
and here the only move that wins is
bishop to f7
now the point is that if black now
removes the defender now we have this
incredible rook to g8 check and that
will remove the queen king captures an
f7 rook captures on g5
and now of course if h captures d
capture z and of course we have a rook
against tonight in a completely winning
end game there's there's no way
uh you you will ever get out of this so
instead after bishop to f7 we have king
the h7
you can't really go knight grabbing here
so bishop to g8 to check
king to g7 now bishop d5 again
threatening the same thing so came to h7
and now rook the g8 winning a lot of
very important squares here like we said
the queen
doesn't really have all that uh uh all
that uh
you know anywhere to go to uh you could
go to h5 but it's again such such an
ugly square not a lot to do there
for for the black queen and if you try
to give back some material it's still
lost i mean it's a knight
and rook against the bishop and knight
and you are up upon of course it's a
completely winning end game
so instead after rook the g8 we have
bishop to g7
blocking this attack and now comes rook
to e8
so what do you play here now the threat
is this very very annoying bishop
to g8 and well this is covered by the
knight so we're going to have to go
under the mask
and well then it's just going to be a
very very happy you know
a windmill action time so here black
finally eliminates one of the attackers
we have rook captures on e5 and queen g4
so now the queen
gets some squares uh attacks this rook
on d1 but now rook d3 again
not a single square for this queen to
join the attack
we have f for now trying to create some
chances here but now
king to b4 look at this beauty even some
poetic action at the end of the game
because the knight is now trapped
the bishop covers the the escape squares
so here we have
f captures on g3 but now white just
played rook the e7 check
and he was in this position uh on move
44 that paolo poncreto resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh here if you continue and you can
never go um
uh you you can never go for example to
the g6 because then rook captures and g3
just wins the queen on the spot so you'd
have to play king to h8
but then we force the king there rookie
checking h7 and now bishop to e4
checking out you have to
go to the g file kg7 now we're going to
play rook captures on g3
win the queen that's it queen capture
spawn captures and
to make matters worse the knight still
has no squares the bishop covers all the
escape square so it's just a
a very very sad night it's been there
for like forever and it didn't really
you know it was supposed to be a great
attacker but
you know it's a very very sad uh so yeah
after rook the e7 check uh pancreato
resigned and uh an amazing victory for
round one in uh for atm backroad
uh who will of course uh tomorrow uh
need only a draw to advance into the
the next round though the feeder world
cup so incredible game
thank you so much for suggesting it
everyone uh but there there were so many
people you know
posting about it it was uh it was really
a no brainer but
like i said if you have any any more of
the games that you would like to see i
may have time tomorrow before the
the next round starts to show another
one uh for the moment it's either
estipenko versus dubo or vidid versus
xiong but to do
do keep suggesting and we'll see also
use the comment section you know that
that also works
uh so yeah uh once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
stephen winford matthew parker tom
darylle richard campbell and robert
walker for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the video world cup checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
sorry about a bit of a longer video
see you soon